actress Candace Cameron Beret is
speaking out on The Firestorm over her
words wanting to keep traditional
marriage at the core of her Network's
holiday movies our words matter in a
lengthy statement this afternoon Candace
didn't explain why Great American Family
won't feature same-sex couples but said
quote I am called to love all people and
I do adding I had also expressed in my
interview which was not included that
people of all ethnicities and identities
have and will continue to contribute to
the network in great ways both in front
of and behind the camera which I
encourage and fully support
Hollywood is already taking sides One
Tree Hill and Hallmark star Hillary
Burton called Candace a bigot JoJo siwa
who famously called Candace the rudest
celebrity she ever met said it's rude
and hurtful to a whole community of
people Candace's Fuller house co-star
Jody Sweetin weighed in commenting on
JoJo's post you know I love you
let's [ __ ] me juice
Jody took his further and seemed to
shade Candace
urging support on Instagram for the
respect for Marriage Act which would
protect same-sex unions Candace's
daughter however she's standing by her
have you even seen all my Christmas
movies I've seen a majority of them
Natasha Bray wrote her favorite thing
about her mom is quote how much she
loves Jesus and How firm in her faith
she stands she's definitely worked her
hardest and just kind of stood her
ground and
um you know given the glory to God and
stayed by her family I found this Bible
to be so special Candace's latest
holiday film a Christmas present
premieres November 27th on Great
American Family another big aspect
within the script and for me personally
is Faith Merry Christmas
she's also Chief creative officer for
the network I am just lined up yes
um there's gonna be more Christmas after
Christmas more Christmas because I'm
going to be planning a lot more of the
Slate for 2023 Christmas
[Music]